lui e giovanni ciao questa mia comunque
dovresti carlone e mio questo è ok
allora ragazzi oggi vi racconto una
storia un po particolare però che credo
sia importante soprattutto dirla in un
rocket league
episodio che visto che ho detto
qualsiasi cosa ha raccontato anche di
quando non mi si alzava quindi posso
raccontarvi anche di questo insomma
questa domanda mi è stata fatta dai dai
tempi dei sei ancora prima che iniziasse
a fare youtube una domanda particolare
era chi è stato prima fa su youtube
ecco questa cosa è un po combattuta
perché io so chi è stato il mio primo
fan su youtube però mi sento di volerne
nominare nominare data al nostro non
nominiamo nessuno perché come sempre non
dico mai nomi veri delle persone nei
video di rocket league
però mi sento di spiegarvi chi sono
questi fan perché ce n'è più di uno
perché io so chi è stato il mio primo
fan come fa vj e so chi è stato il mio
primo fan in assoluto su youtube che io
non lo sapete non ha iniziato con questo
canale ma ho iniziato a fare video con
altri ragazzi mickey box come quale
faccio il demone in gaming e ai tuffo
avevamo questo canale chiamato the scene
di gaming ok il gioco condiviso fare
video su youtube non era non rendeva
famosi cioè le persone su youtube non
erano famose ok quindi era impensabile
venire riconosciuti per strada tipo un
cantante tipo
queste c persona nello spettacolo che
l'intrattenimento pubblico perché
youtuber non erano famosi ok cioè non
riconosciuti giro facciamo una cosa
particolare un po come se tu oggi ti
metti ad attaccare gli adesivi
sull'armadio è per qualche strano motivo
la gente ti riconosce le super strada
perché lo fai dice ma io ho attaccato
gli adesivi sull'armadio e dici ok però
mi piace quello che fai ti stimo va bene
quindi stavo dicendo ero con il di share
e di gaming quindi con i miei compagni
ex compagni classe nichi box e ai puffo
aveva aperto il nostro canale da circa
un annetto più o meno e facevamo ai
tempi facevamo andava a scuola in un
tecnico informatico quindi gente che già
smanettava sul computer di base
ok quindi riconoscerci veniva più facile
perché non è che andavi tipo
all'artistico che magari avevano mai
acceso un computer
sto scherzando le sette dell'artistico
ovviamente o forse no e comunque la
gente già era abbastanza smanettona ci è
capitato un giorno mentre camminavamo
per il corridoio di incontrare un
ragazzo un ragazzo che ci guarda ci vede
eravamo io e luca o dimenticate di luca
sarebbe ai tuffo eravamo io è il buffo
che era appunto i due dei tre componenti
delle cere gaming parola parlottava mo
nel corridoio della scuola
a un certo punto ragazzo ci ferma ci fa
ma voi siete fa vj a e il tuffo
certo come possibile invece perché i
tempi ecco di caterina che sta cosa ai
tempi noi non mettevamo la webcam
quindi non ci non si sapevano le nostre
facce sentire come gara col tipo la
radio sentivi solo gente che parlava col
gameplay
ok quindi non potevi sapere la nostra
faccia solo la nostra voce e ci ha
riconosciuto dalla voce ce li abbiamo
sentiti parlare mi sembrate proprio loro
ci siamo noi
mi ricordo di questo ragazzo sono
armando ma ovviamente no però immettiamo
i nomi che veniva alla nostra scuola e
ci aveva riconosciuti perché ci seguiva
un fantastico più è stato il nostro
primo faccia e la nostra prima persona
incontrata in real life che ci seguiva
sui video questo è successo più o meno
nel 2011 2012 più o meno quindi questo è
stato il primo fun fun
c'è insomma persone che ci seguiva il
contratto nella storia ok ora il
professore funded del the share e vieni
il primo vero fan di fabi j
quindi del mio canale diciamo che questa
è una storia un po più articolata allora
i miei primi fan incontrati proprio di
persona in giro quindi che mi hanno
riconosciuto per il mio canale li
incontrai alte al tempo al torino comics
torino comics del 2013
perché io nel 2013 andai al torino
comics avevo aperto il mio canale da
qualche mese aveva già fatto un sacco di
iscritti più del the share e gang però
avevo iniziato cioè io il mio canale
quadro ho messo la webcam quindi la
gente mi riconosceva mi vedeva in faccia
e avevo detto che sarei andato al torino
comics
quindi io al torino comics vi sono
trovato questo gruppo di ragazzi
all'entrata proprio perché questi casi
esaltavano perché so per entrare noe e
faceva molto strano io mi ricordo che
stavo entrando proprio nell'entrata del
torino comics c'erano queste tre o
quattro persone ferme che appena mi
hanno visto entrare si sono esaltate
subito perché non so perché stavano
aspettando me e questa è stata la prima
volta in assoluto che io ho votato dei
miei fan solo miei primi non delle cere
gaming ed è stato molto molto
emozionante ok ho dovuto firmare i primi
autografi e stato molto kringe ma molto
divertente ai tempi erano i primi si
incontri con la mia prima ragazza
ok quella degli altri video di rocket
league il giorno dopo portai anche lei
al torino capri ci andai 22 volte il
giorno prima con la classe c con la mia
classe erano adatti a torino comics e
quindi tutti questi fan mi hanno
riconosciuto nel mentre chi va in giro
con la mia classe b che era ridicolo ma
allo stesso tempo mi piaceva un sacco
il giorno dopo con la mia ex ragazza
sempre un sacco di persone mi hanno
riconosciuto e quindi vi facciamo tutto
il figlio tipso famoso io è stai con uno
che è famoso non è vero non diciamo ste
cagate però lo so io sarebbe stato una
passata introverso quindi vedermi
riconosciuto in giro con una ragazza di
fianco era tipo figo no avevo 16 anni
dan europea del che comunque non vi ha
detto comunque chi sono stati i miei
primi fan su fa vj perché questi sono i
primi che mi hanno riconosciuto in real
life ma io so di tutti questi scritti
che voi state vedendo che sono 516
milioni di tutti questi chi è stato il
primo in assoluto
ok io lo conosco il conosco questa
persona il primo iscritto al mio canale
il primo di tutti questi 5,6 milioni di
fan il primo iscritto in assoluto è una
ragazza con la quale io avevo avuto una
tra virgolette relazione a distanza
perché ho fatto le virgolette nel mentre
che deve parare fantastico ho avuto una
relazione a distanza con questa persona
una ragazza siciliana che mi seguiva dal
the chair and gaming insomma
insomma parlavamo tutto il giorno a
distanza perché eravamo insomma eravamo
presi beni innamorati insomma anche se
era una cosa molto molto infantile
perché comunque non c'eravamo mai
neanche visti quindi quando vedi poi una
persona che si trovi a passare il tempo
insieme poi è tutto diverso
eravamo insomma degli amici di penna 2.0
molto oltre quindi innamoratini
ovviamente non la considero una ragazza
con la volete uno stato perché per
niente perché non siamo neanche visti
una volta sarebbe strano anzi mi farebbe
piacere mi ricordo che ai tempi ancora
stavamo ci stavamo sentendo io ho aperto
il mio canale lei sapeva di tutto questo
mio progetto aperto il mio canale gli
poi glielo linkato e lei si è iscritta
quindi mio primo iscritto vero di parigi
tv su questo canale di aciclico a 6
milioni è stata una è una ragazza
siciliana che tra l'altro non sento qua
ogni tanto capita di selvaggio che un
messaggio volante e niente lei è stato
il mio primo c'è in realtà non fanno mai
scritto al canale questa cosa qua è
molto simpatica perché se adesso guardo
sotto numero abnorme di fan
io riesco a c'è so qual è il primo è che
è veramente assurdo se ci pensate perché
sono veramente tanti sapere di tutti i
fan
chi è il primo è veramente impossibile
qua è quasi impossibile quasi
impossibile ragazzi questa era questo lo
vedo molto visi però sono molto sincero
mi fa molto piacere condividerlo con voi
perché c'è per me è importante sapere e
ricordare queste cose perché se io penso
all'inizio della mia carriera
in questa stanza in questo post militato
questo video è proprio azzeccato per
l'argomento
se io penso ripenso al tutto quello che
è stato
la mia partenza anche ricordarsi di
questi momenti queste piccole cose che
per alcuni magari sono va bene ora ne è
un miliardo di fano ok però le prime
situazioni del genere in qualche modo ti
rimangono dentro è proprio la bella cosa
una bellissima un bellissimo ricordo
anche perché mi ricordo proprio l'enfasi
che c'erano
mi conosceva l'inizio è quella che è la
stessa enfasi che avevo io dicevo ma
veramente mi sta riconoscendo qualcuno e
che incredibile questi erano i miei
primi fan in assoluto sia da di share e
gaming che ti fa vigeva molto strano
perché se vi racconto questa chicca voi
vi ricordate ovviamente un miglior no
quando io feci comico la prima volta era
dicembre del 2013 il primo video di ogni
gol era uno speciale 300.000 iscritti
scrivete speciali 300.000 scritti lo
trovate ero in questa stanza con i
capelli un po diversi ma ero io e la
gente che mi riconosceva soligo si
esaltavano esaltavano di ossigeno che
questa cosa era poco digerita dal
pubblico del senso che la gente diceva
perché questi si esaltano perché hanno
visto uno che fa i video su youtube
c'era scopo strano era difficile da
digerire come cosa no per me invece era
abbastanza normale perché ormai era
dicembre da un sacco di tempo che la
gente aveva iniziato a riconoscermi
anche per strada quindi io sapevo che la
gente avrebbe reagito così quando ho
fatto miccoli lo sapevo che la
situazione sarebbe stata questa però non
per il pubblico del web dei tempi per
loro era tutto un facciamo questi da
urlare dall'ipo è nata anche un po di
invidia che posso capire perché non
avrei avuto l'elasticità mentale di
capire che se una persona è conosciuta
perché sta facendo qualcosa
questi risultati gli i primi fan ragazzi
questi sono ricordi che non abbandonerò
mai tutti in questa camera tra l'altro
tutto tutto iniziato qua vado a piangere
adesso se mi date un attimo compiuto il
video da piangere
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
iscrivetevi al canale e schiacciate il
tasto mi piace date vederlo speciale
300.000 iscritti che bo e noi come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video
della ragazza
[Musica]